[Music]
we're just with Bill Hader and he was
doing impression so know that you you do
a lot of voices on Robot Chicken George
funny show Robot Chicken and Robot
Chicken it's a it's a it's a great show
an animated show with a lot of little
action figure characters yeah mr. Seth
Green created the show yeah and you mean
I do invoices for it for a long time
we've been do it yeah we've been right
on it and we've been doing for eight
years now even Robot Chicken you guys do
a lot of sort of Star Wars yeah we did
this we do the Star Wars specials and
stuff are there any voices that you
really like to do I do well I get to do
Boba Fett which is like the dream
because unless JJ calls by the way you
can but this is the show where we're
auditioning people I'm not gonna be
playing Boba Fett right but so this
might be the only platform in which I
got to go for it but was Robot Chicken
yeah I made Boba Fett sound like just I
always thought he would which was just
I'm really cool and I got no problems at
all you know what's going on just going
into my slave one ship right now and me
and the frozen you know Han Solo gonna
take a little trip down to happy land
you know and just say you're probably
that's just a guy that just doesn't he's
he's very laid-back he's really sexy
when it gets into those like so we gonna
do this sexy voice yeah yeah now this is
I thought you and I were gonna get it oh
you mean get it on yeah I got another
chick in the tub if you're down
sexually it's awfully just like my dad
well that's how we all doing sexy yep is
my dad you know you've always been
fascinated I know with Matthew
McConaughey you love Matthew McConaughey
and he won a Golden Globe just very
recently like a week and a half ago he
won the Golden Globe and I'm he gave
this speech I bet you were loved I was I
did a movie with McConaughey and I
played his brother and when I was
auditioning if you hear his accent you
can't help but not you can't help but do
it
so he's sitting there going at my
character named Polly and he's doing
this thing was like Polly we're gonna do
this and bye-bye when I'm like you bet
we are
and I was like he's gonna think I'm
mocking him he said he's like we cut the
seniors like so Brecon where he from and
I was like it's gonna be weird if I say
la and when I saw the Golden Gloves he
did like the perfect storm of
McConaughey he did all right all right
when he got up there the first thing he
did yeah first thing is all right all
right and then he did JK live and you
know just keep living his right company
and all and then he always does some
backwards amazing I got a dog in a fight
but this dog won't bite you're like yes
you're a wise one yeah I understand yeah
you're like the you're like a really
cool obi-wan who's just like Luke look
within yourself and then come over to my
place while Bongo I don't
[Laughter]